next question
dr peter mccullough stated that one
cannot get coveted 19 twice that is
cannot be reinfected can you elaborate
and confirm thank you both very much
um can't confirm it
can say
the the question is this and i know
because i asked peter myself
the
kind of immunity generated by infection
that is to say natural immunity is
extremely broad and apparently very
long-lived and so
the
game that we are playing with these
current vaccines is a very different
thing and the proxy that we're using for
how immune you are which is whether you
have a an antibody response is a
terrible proxy right because your
antibodies actually ought to die away
and ideally what we want is
t cell based immunity right which does
not produce antibodies
but anyway
so the the question is this you have a
small number of cases in which people
who have natural immunity appear to get
coded
are those because their original case of
covid wasn't really covered did they get
a false positive with their original
case they've actually never had covid
and then they get covered the first time
and we say it's a reinfection
is the second case of covet a false
positive is it a mixture of those and if
you got rid of all of the false positive
indications on either first or second
infection would there be anybody left
over who had a healthy immune system and
had had two cases of covet prior to
omicron that's the question peter says
no he says there's no evidence for a
case that does not look like a false
positive of one sort or another
in which somebody was reinfected which
would be a great thing to be able to say
i don't think it's important
even if there are rare cases of
reinfection they are rare cases that
much is very clear at least would be
lovely if it were clean that would be
great i think i i think could it could
become important at least as a
as a political tool and i mean that in
the best sense of the word if it were if
if it were
if it were true and demonstrably so
uh that you really could not get
reinfected um you know including for
instance omicron having had the original
variant yeah um that would that would be
huge
um especially since there's a whole lot
of people garbage arguing about like
natural immunity not even being useful
at all which is i mean
they're just making no sense at all
they're not responding to any of the
abundant evidence out there and so the
cleaner the clearer the more absolute
the actual evidence is the better
uh but i don't expect you know biology
being a complex system i don't expect us
to get something quite so clean
especially given what you suggested
about omicron maybe being able to evade
natural immunity from various infections
i think there's an even better reason
that clean would be
important which is you know i do
occasionally hear somebody say that
natural immunity ain't all that um which
is obviously a nonsense argument that
doesn't stand up to evidence um
but what does get said which i find
totally diabolical
is that what you really want is super
immunity and so if you've had covet you
still need to get the vaccine well isn't
that amazing no matter what the case is
you still need the vaccine no matter how
safe you are by virtue of being young
and healthy no matter how immune you are
by virtue of having had covid you still
need the vaccine because that's the
important thing is the vaccine right or
how much emerging evidence on original
antigenic sin there might be out there
right none of it nothing nothing you
just simply that no matter what the
evidence does the conclusion of certain
people will always be the same and um so
the point is if you really if there
really were no cases
none at all rather than just vanishingly
rare then you could say yeah super
immunity is not a thing if you've had
code you're done it's just it just makes
it easier but it's i mean it's like it's
like
the kids and how at risk they are and um
and whether or not they need the
vaccines
um yes there are
some children who have died
and any child's death i think is a
tragedy actually um but
but it's so vanishingly small that the
idea that we should be treating
five-year-olds the same way we treat
eighty-year-olds
uh with regard to you know fear of this
disease and and treatment is badly
insane the kids are all right but we're
going to vaccinate them anyway yeah but
we're going to fix that
[Music]
you